so good to see you bro
great to see you again yeah always yeah
always great to see you and i think that
a lot of people would consider uh us to
be
an
unlikely uh
friendship
not not people who know me right anybody
anybody and i love it
i love you too i i love you so much
and uh
we met in 2009 when we were on dancing
with the stars
i don't even remember years i don't do
years
i don't do years sometime in the past
okay steve does years days months he
remembers days oh i have friends that
can remember you know every event at
apple for example right to the exact
week and the day of what we did this on
wednesday then i don't know how they do
it and some people remember names and
faces but i have a disease called
prosopagnosia 150 people have it and i
can't recognize faces
oh wow yeah what do you recognize
voices voices i can recognize stories
things we did i remember all that
and uh just every face is kind of the
same even janet's i make mistake both
directions wow wow
i remember the time i was in saudi
arabia and they had this mess on you
could only see the eyes but i could tell
it was janet's eyes so i squeezed her
butt and it wasn't janet
that's great
like just a joke just sit here
every comedian you know has to kind of
rules rules don't matter that much guys
i love it i i love it and um steve has a
co-host blindness where he doesn't
introduce me or paul sometimes
well i mean he met scott randolph and
and this is the gorgeous paul briskey
it's a pleasure to meet you steve yeah
yeah great yeah great to be here i wish
we could do this more often man and i
watched your show and said oh gosh i
want to be there place to tell you know
interesting stories a little out of the
normal yeah absolutely and um i i did
what an honor to be able to do this with
you i just learned that the reason why
you were on dancing with the stars
where we met
was because of mark cuban
no oh no no
um deena katz okay and her husband was
in the technology and suggested me and
she was one of the producers i remember
i remember dina county she brought me on
and to this day when she asked me to go
on certain shows or events i do it
because it's her i like her very much
yeah and she was the one now mark cuban
during dancing with the stars i had so
many injuries from moving my body in
ways you've never moved it before i had
a broken toe i couldn't feel for weeks
and then finally got it they did an
x-ray it was broken but everything hurt
every single toe all the way up to your
hips hurt that much trying this for so
long and uh mark cuban at one point um i
the paparazzi got onto i was wearing a
cast on my foot for a while
and he got onto and he phoned and said
he had a doctor who would help me out
with advice i don't know what to do what
not to do yeah i love him that was
really nice i've met him a couple times
yeah i think he's great he is great man
i wish he were president but
yeah
um
and and i think that
one of the greatest moments of dancing
with this star's history is you doing
the worm
don't ask me we were in rehearsal and
somebody said oh you could do the worm
what's the worm
and so one of one of the technical guys
filmers he tried to emulate it okay and
then i didn't practice it at all i
didn't not no idea how to do it maybe i
practice it one one or two times you
know like for ten years it was it was
and i said will i do it on the show
it couldn't have been better it could
not have been more a more entertaining
moment
thank god i'm so proud to be known for
that i don't care if they gave us a 10
total score
you know but um oh no that was uh yeah
memorable moments i love to be a part of
them and then you guys struck up a
friendship on dancing with stars like
very much did how did that kind of grow
and start i don't remember steve might
have come to talk to me and just
somebody talks to me as a friend i'm
really shy i don't meet many friends but
no i um i don't know if you ever got i
went out for every one of the
the 27 celebrities and professional
dancers and i made little bags of gifts
little gift bags and i i'll tell you
when you're rehearsing you don't have
any spare time drove around to to
bookstore after bookstore after
bookstore always looked for books that
had little like factoid type books
different different ones not every bag
was i remember and then i then i put in
a sheet of two dollar bills strange to
have them on sheets put in for everybody
and i put in my metal business cards i
have these with me
and uh put them in there and then i i
typed a letter on a computer about what
a great experiences was and i put it in
every bag for 27 others but then for
each of the 27 yourself included i hand
wrote in cursive a note as to why they
were good people wow every single one of
them and the next season i told donny
osmond about he said he was going to do
it but he never had the time yeah i mean
that that's what that was that was but i
was figured i'm going to get kicked off
real soon and i better get this done
because everybody gives gifts and i'm
going to be out of the loop and that's
why that's why i was rushing to do it
wow i think that's a dying art now
dancing with the stars yeah you were one
of the greatest discoveries in dancing
with the stars you know of course all
the people and how the show was made but
uh man we were we had to go i ride my
segway to the show oh yeah and i and i
passed by this wood ranch barbecue they
won't have them up in northern
california that is still my favorite
place janet and i will drive down south
just to go to a wood ranch um just i'm
addicted to their i don't know their
barbecue sauce wow
nice and then that was i associate that
with dancing with the stars i don't
remember too much of the actual dancing
right yeah
the wood ranch that's what we got yeah i
mean it's a story i've told so many
times but i'll never forget how
i i got i too got injured my back was
was hurt on dancing with the stars and i
told you on the set that i was thinking
about getting a macbook air so that my
backpack would be lighter because it was
hurting my back and when you heard that
right away you said oh cool i'll go with
you to the apple store
yeah and you can use my 10 employee
discount yeah and i just thought that
was so fantastically hilarious i said
there is no way i'm going to turn down
an opportunity to go to the apple store
with the waz and uses 10 discounts i
helped a couple other dancers that
wanted to get new phones or something
but i really saved the life of jonathan
roberts or somebody um he was one of the
professional dancers his phone went bad
that day and he ran down to the um
uh sherman oaks uh mall and he knocked
on the apple's door we don't open for an
hour we don't open until 11. he says
i've got to get to the show uh st
wozniak is on they opened the door and
got him and said wow
yeah that's glad for that
and uh and he got you the discount when
you went to he did yeah and it was the
craziest experience because this apple
employee
steve called it called him over and he
said hey my friend here is going to buy
this computer and use my discount and
this guy somehow didn't recognize steve
oh that said
you know what 40 years ago i was 30.
he
looked at him and he said but are you an
apple employee and steve cheerfully said
yeah i have an apple employee number
it's one
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you